ça traoré comparaissait au tribunal pour
diffamation a signé par les trois
gendarmes qui ont interpellé son frère
adama traoré
cela fait suite à une tribune de juillet
2019 qu'elle avait écrite
reprenant le j'accuse d'emile zola sur
l' affaire dreyfus dans un tribunal les
accusés d'avoir tué son frère adama en
l'écrasant du poids de leur corps elles
les sites et nominativement d'où la
procédure en diffamation intenté par les
trois gendarmes
le procureur aujourd'hui a expliqué
qu'il fallait distinguer droit à
l'indignation de la diffamation et que
la tribune était disproportionnée quel
qui était la justesse du combat qu'elle
entendait mener
en revanche l'avocat dassa traoré maître
yassine bouzrou a longuement plaidé à
expliquer en quoi la tribune de sa
cliente utiliser des bases factuelles de
la procédure
je vous propose d'écouter maître bouzrou
et assa traoré il y a une dizaine de
médecins qui ont trahi sur ce dossier
qui affirme très clairement que
l'interpellation a causé la mort et pas
seulement des médecins français et
également des médecins américains
notamment le médecin qui travaille sur
l'affairé floyd des médecins légistes
brésiliens des médecins français des
médecins belges désigné par les juges
d'instruction donc nous avons seulement
des médecins choisi par la famille mais
également des médecins choisis par les
juges d'instruction qui indique
clairement que si adama traoré n'avait
pas été interpellé par les gendarmes il
ne serait pas mort
donc ma cliente dénonce dans un texte
qui s'intitule j'accuse tous ces
éléments factuels précis parce qu'elle a
raison de le faire en se basant sur des
éléments objectifs
les gendarmes sont responsables de la
mort de mon petit frère comme mon avocat
maître yassine bouzrou viens de le dire
tous des éléments
tous les éléments sont là et tous les
éléments mettent en cause les gendarmes
aujourd'hui la justice française doit
prendre ses responsabilités et nous
devons aller tous devant un procès
public
aujourd'hui la sphère adama traoré est
une affaire qui est devenue nationale
ce sont des questions qui
n'appartiennent plus qu'à la famille
traoré mais qui appartiennent à la
france entière les deux jours de procès
sont donc écoulés en l'absence des trois
gendarmes et le délibéré a été porté au
1er juillet